[Musique]
salut il ya quelques temps à la vidéo
city paris j'ai rencontré l'inventeur
cet instrument il a happé sable du halo
c'est un truc un peu haut qui permet de
faire de la musique même quand tu
connais rien j'ai donc proposé de passer
nos karine des mots et surtout pour
comprendre le processus créatif qui
l'emmenait inventé ça restait bien
jusqu'au bout de la vidéo j'ai un truc
sympa vous dire à la fin et en parlant
de latin guillet pas combien nouveau
rituel ensemble sur les deux dernières
secondes de la vidéo je vous mets un
panneau vous retrouvez les prochaines
dates de dédicace du livre
la date de la prochaine vidéo la date du
prochain live et d'autres infos quand il
ya d'autres en tout ça on a trouvé
l'objet le plus satisfaisant du monde
ses fans szpiner s'était ça l'objet le
plus satisfaisant du monde mon gars tu
as j'ai des étoiles dans les yeux quand
tu joues quoi ok alors je mange à vue là
[Musique]
voilà ça m'affecte pas trop l'habitude
n'y a pas de souci et maintenant on va
faire la basse ok mais voilà pour cette
touche la paire d'as et laurie et du
couvent est joué juste et correct et sup
lâcher quoi d'ailleurs pour ceux qui
coûtent français mettre le casque
entente règne là-bas sache que les démos
qui est sans doute une petite après midi
et surtout que tueur du lot en fait ce
que vous pensez que c'est une communauté
de joueurs et tu peux baisser son match
comme ça et en fait sur du halloween
toute une communauté de joueurs et ce
qu'on fait et qu'on fait un morceau le
morceau c'est un fichier qui est là
dedans ils vont pour le partage sur
internet et n'importe qui peut le
télécharger le mettre dedans on partage
les sont aussi d'accord la semence cela
parle anglais sur notre site
donc si tu veux refaire chez profiles où
tu télécharges c'est à dire que des sons
qui vont avec une mer prélevés lobbies
la patelière fait à ta sauce comment
est-ce que ça t'est venue de créer ça
peut-être pas l'objet tel qu'il est
finie aujourd'hui en tout cas tu as base
d'idées c'était quoi alors à la base
donc c'était déjà ce concert avec moi je
suis musicien batteur
ouais mais fanfaron ok j'ai fait de la
fanfare pendant dix ans je faisais du
trombone voilà et ce qui me faisait qui
fait dans la fanfare c'est que je jouais
à 50 centimètres des gens qu'on dit mais
pourquoi il est notes sont disposés
comme ça sur un piano puis je demander
s'il est pas plus malin et j'ai été
inspiré par l'instrument qui s'appelle
la senza hockey la senza c'est un
instrument africain et c'est typiquement
le genre d'instrument octobre à
quelqu'un quand tu sais pas que lui
offrir le kayak et musicien je sais pas
quoi lui offrir tout york en scène en
afrique on utilise des gammes
pentatoniques cd gamma sept à cinq notes
et en europe on utilise des gammes à
cette note doré mi fa sol la si do
compte bien et elles sont disposées de
façon alternative
en gros c'est disposer comme ça do ré mi
fa sol la si do voilà ça c'est la gamme
la gamme ou la coupe en deux comme ça du
coup là on a une note sur deux et en
musique y croyez moi sur parole en
musique
si on prenait 2 sur deux ça fait un
accord du coup la découverte et la gb
sassou mais demain je vais un accord
dans la main droite un accord dans la
main gauche et du coup bah tiens tu vas
le faire
les notes qui sont les unes à côté des
autres c'est une note d accord et donc
des clichés trois touches d'affilée ça
sonne bien
je serai touche qui sont limitées sûr
que ça sonne et du coup la famille on va
faire la gamme donc je compose la lettre
à élise hockey est mort ce que tu vas
faire c'est que alternait gauche à
droite donc index index majeur majeur
vas-y voilà il a refait la même chose
sans toucher les touches voilà parfait
toi tu as tu a réadapté du coup toutes
les couleurs à chaque fois il ya juste à
suivre en fait j'ai juste à suivre et et
affiche la gamme que tu veux si tu veux
jouer en chais pas moins gamme orientale
tu mets la gamme orientale et tuque qc
ca voilà du coup les accords c'est des
dessins les games et des dessins du coup
c'est hyper visuel comme un clavier et
voilà ils parient en fait c'est que nous
on est des homo sapiens et homo sapiens
ils sont ils ont une mémoire plus tôt
visuels et du coup c'est un instrument
qui est fait pour nous moi je vais voir
pas mal de concerts de hip hop d'électro
et je trouve ça dommage chaque fois les
dj ils sont comme ça sur la table et que
leur carte que là et tu les vois tourner
les boutons mais n'entend pas ce que ça
fait et du coup là ce que je voulais
c'était que soit l'instrument le public
voit ce qui se passe donc là si tu joues
comme un trader par exemple bas là les
mecs qui vont capter on dira plutôt que
fabien est déchiré jeu trop vite et tout
voilà on s'y voit que t'es en train de
si tu vois que tu es en train d'appuyer
là bas ils savent que tu es en train de
choisir son etc
moi quand je te regarde jouer ou quand
je vous regarde vous sur le net je vois
toute la corée en fait tu vois ce qui se
passe et du coup une telle le show même
à regarder la personne jouer c'est beau
de voir là bas confirmant un dj pour le
coup comme tu dis que tu vois pas ce
qu'il fait c'est ma réellement et c'est
dommage parce qu'il est dj dj qu'il faut
vraiment des choses extraordinaires en
termes de instrumentale mais s'il ne
partage pas avec leur public là l'idée
c'est de partager le jeu musical avec le
public que je trouve que c'est un objet
qui est satisfaisant soit parce que à
partir du moment où tu arrives à faire
de la création sur un domaine de
compétence que t'as pas toi tu vas là en
l'occurrence la musique c'est comme si
demain quelqu'un invente un truc qui me
fait bien dessiné tu vois je vais ça va
me rendre dingue tu as toujours
l'impression qu'un instrument si tu ne
maîtrises pas assez compte nab le menton
fera rien alors que là tu peux passer on
va dire t'amuser assez rapidement si tu
retiens les principes
le fait que ce soit des dessins le fait
que tout soit en visuel le fait que ce
soit éclairé et et début de gamme nous
ici je sais déjà vous le savez qu'on a
une mémoire visuelle parce qu'on en
parle tous les torts dans cette chaîne
mais du coup c'est hyper adapté
la preuve je vous promets que j'avais
jamais essayé avant est vraiment jamais
à part regarder les vidéos en battant et
en faisant un message pourrait jamais
c'est comment tu peux avoir une idée de
départ sur un instrument africain est
arrivé à ça ouais alors je vais
t'expliquer parce que du coup la base
y'a la disposition des noces et je te
raconter donc en fait je ne sais pas si
tu as déjà fait une vidéo là dessus mais
autant le coup de foudre
je ne sais pas si ça existe autant le
vrai qu'à je peux témoigner ça existe
j'ai eu cette idée là en fait ces deux
ans plus tard ou gelée vraiment vraiment
qui scindait dans ma tête avec les avec
tout ce réseau hexagonal
il était 4 heures du matin je me suis
réveillé en sueur et je me suis
précipité sur mon ordi j'ai dessiné ce
clavier je vais imprimer et j'ai joué
toute la nuit sur la table comme ça va
faire tout tout révéler ma copine
d'ailleurs enfin bref toutes les idées
sont arrivés très naturellement et en
trois semaines j'avais dans ma tête
l'objet qui étaient là les idées c'est
facile c'est vraiment facile en fait là
j'ai vraiment eu l'impression de tirer
une pelote de laine terre que jamais une
nouvelle disposition des notes
du coup bon bah naturellement aux dif le
mettre sur un instrument naturellement
tu dis bah on va faire un design nouveau
puisque le clavier nouveau donc
à l'époque c'était en 2007 tu vas donc
ce débat c'est quoi qui est qu'est-ce
qu'on rêve d'avoir dans un truc où le
public qui voit ce qu'on joue un truc où
il ya un petit écran on pourra bien
capté un truc où il ya pas besoin
d'ordinateur où on ne peut faire des
boucles ou voilà et toutes ces idées
s'enchaînent petit à petit et du coup
j'ai un peu écrit la lettre au père noël
de l'instrument idéal c'est qu'on est
l'instrument idéal cesser toutes ses
propriétés là et après mon travail ça a
été de trouver le design le plus simple
possible qui permet d'intégrer tout ça
le cas vous entendez peut-être pas
compte en fait mais cet instrument fait
la même chose que les grosses santé
arrangeur yamaha qui sont gros comme ça
et qui coûte 4 mai bal mais juste voilà
moi je suis un fan d'apple donc je
voulais qu'ils aient le moins possible
de boutons quoi alors ça faisait pas on
est là mais mes premières maquettes il y
avait plein de potard de partout et
itunes et plein de fils et tous et puis
petit à petit j'ai essayé de remplacer
les boutons un petit est une idée qui a
été déterminante pour ça c'est
d'utiliser en fait les touches du
clavier qui sont déjà là en fait tu vois
tout à leur compte à choisir son camp le
match en double à chaque touche
correspondance on ya donc et marc à
l'écran et en plus tu ont exploité la
vie' c'est vraiment en plus très
agréable parce que c'est très discret
j'ai jamais percuté dans toutes les
vidéos que j'ai vu des gens qui s'en
servent qui check et un écran c'est
magnifique je suis ravie en fait en
en réalité il ya il ya rien à gagner en
fait c'est pas un placement de produit
j'ai eu la chance qu'on se soit
contactée après rencontrer la vidéo city
cette année et je trouve l'ensemble du
projet ou c'est à dire on parlait de la
créativité de l'idée pour moi la
créativité c'est que tu as accès au
futur en fait dans ta tête tu vois mais
après il ya comment tu vas le mettre en
place qui est génial comment tu va
aboutir à la meilleure version de ton
idée et puis après il ya la musique est
l'instrument en lui-même
et comme je suis dit qu enfin tu vois tu
veux toi tu parlais des notes mais moi
j'ai l'impression que tout se recoupe
dans un seul objet et d'une joue
félicite toute l'équipe toi je te
félicite d'avoir eu cette idée de
l'avoir mené au bout je trouve que c'est
l'objet qu'il faut connaître aujourd'hui
et j'espère qu'il aura de plus en plus
de gens qui font des vidéos là dessus je
sais que youtube jordanie la patrick
desjardins
je trouve ça trouver à moi c'était une
chance en fait de pouvoir vous
rencontrer et de pouvoir l'essayer je
trouve ça use
bravo ben écoute merci à toi et puis bah
comme tu dis si t'es pas en parler
autour de vous
[Musique]
la bonne nouvelle de la fin de cette
vidéo c'est que depuis qu'on a tourné on
a discuté ensemble et on s'est mis
d'accord sur un truc au mois de
septembre à la rentrée on vous faudra
gagner au moins un instrument indus à
l'eau pour vous je deviendrai bien sûr
au courant de tout ça sur les réseaux
sociaux
[Musique]
comme toujours si la vidéo vous appelez
n'oubliez pas d'indiquer et de vous
abonner et à très bientôt de chat
[Musique]